Film Courage: Joe, do you still believe that there will
be blue-collar storytellers or have they already arrived? Joe Wilson, Vampire Mob Creator/Writer/Director: I think they are already here.I think that it's because of
everything that's gone on online there
is not you know it when there were less
movies being made they were worth more
money for everybody and there were also
less jobs for everybody there's never
been more acting jobs in the history of
everything than right now there's never
been more writing jobs than right now
there's never been more directing jobs
than right now there's never been this
much stuff made so I think there's a ton
of opportunities you know in the
industry because there's so much being
made and when there's so much being made
its mass is inherently blue-collar it's
it's not white color in that white color
like directors you know directors are
sort of the white collar worker when you
when when there's 50 of them now it's
just a bunch of people of direct stuff
so when you have all the TV shows all
the films all the stuff that's online
add up all those jobs add up all that
you know again the the guests are Emmy
consideration performance number was
twenty eight hundred and something so
there were that many performances to
consider so when you're in the thousands
just for an Emmy consideration just to
get the nomination and that is only
getting bigger
there is no there the star system the
you know there's not going to be the
star directors there's going to be like
a billion sort of smaller known
directors but I don't think there's
gonna be you know a Martin Scorsese I
don't think that's I think it's gonna be
less of that because there's so much
stuff I think you know there will be
voices that will be you know distinct
and original and different and the part
would be more of those voices because
more stuff's being made
but because it's just like
bird's-eye-view in the 70s you made a
movie that's what people did there was
nothing else to do you went to the
movies or you watched one of three
networks or you read a book read a
magazine went for a walk that was it now
I could sit home and watch the history
of film on YouTube if I want it is
ridiculous how much stuff is online so
saturation naturally displaces special
so special is is you know stars and that
kind of thing
blue collar is like there's a ton of
people doing these jobs now so to be
famous to be a star I don't know there's
famous people but there's also a lot of
famous people we don't know because we
don't watch that show and the show's
been on for nine years but still I've
never watched Big Bang Theory still
haven't seen it no idea don't care and
just like there's sort of this
middle-class squeeze you know especially
we don't have you know last few years
and in the u.s. do you think it's the
same with artists there's there's the
blue-collar artists and there's a whole
bunch of the blue-collar artists and
then there's the white collar ones and
very little middle-class or I'm just
making this up um yeah I don't I think
would be more like middle and then upper
like I sort of feel like if you're if
you're working in the industry and you
know making a living you know most most
of the people work on stuff or not you
know again it's a temp gig it's a temp
gig and then when that temp gig ends you
got to get another temp cake so you can
pay the mortgage and if you don't get
another temp gig and then you don't get
another temp gig after that and then
months go by that's a problem but I I
just I think there's going
less stars more famous people not as
famous because I'm never I had never
seen this many actors in my life I've
never even off the top of my head even
knowing just think of just the TV shows
movies you've seen in the last year so
much more than what would have been
washed in previous years because the
delivery system is the Internet it's
what everyone else is doing it becomes
habit then we're talking about it online
it becomes behavior and that was the
thing when you were trying to get people
to change their behavior from watching a
TV show at a certain time in a certain
day and then you were getting changing
their behavior by here's the entire
season watch it and then that behavior
changed like although 10 years ago all
the web series people were saying oh
yeah five minutes is too long five
movies is way too long
no one's gonna watch five minutes no one
has time to watch five minutes you're an
idiot if you're making something it
should be three minutes
that's how long has much time people
have and and and they were all wrong
yeah some people want to watch three
minutes but in terms of like an
overarching philosophy on human behavior
no wrong what human beings will do is
sit down and watch 12 hours of
television because it's brand-new and
they want to be able to talk about
stranger things at the office on Monday
new behavior so remind me again what a
blue collar artist is blue collar
screenwriter blue collar directives and
blue collar is is less known less you
know more scrappy not necessarily
scrappy I think it's literally just from
saturation because in the 70s if you had
the number of movies that came out in
the year and the number of TV shows that
came out in 1975 and you added them all
up and now everything that came out 20
18 and you added them all up it would be
a skyscraper maybe a little too
two-story building here's 1975 here's
now all these movies and TV shows and
actors so when you have this much I'm a
director really what did you direct well
there's only this much because it's 1975
it's not that hard
oh you directed something
what did you direct everybody there's a
lot of stuff to pay attention to when
there's a lot it becomes less special
less valuable less less it becomes less
because there's so much you don't feel
like it's it's like the kid who has one
toy and the kid loves that toy because
the kid only has one toy and then
there's the kid who's got aunts and
uncles who has been burying that kid in
every toy it's got every toy
none of them are special because there's
a million of them you only have that one
that's special so when you have you know
a handful of people who are allowed to
make movies and back and now it's that
that's a bigger pile of people there's
way more and it's less precious it's
less special you know honestly no one
gives a rat about the Oscars not that
they really gave a rat that much before
but if you look at the reality of box
office Oscars are not catering to the
public they are catering to the Academy
people speaker King
well that was - yeah but I mean they
were streakers yeah but but that idea of
you know the oh it's an Oscar winning
special you know it's it's scarcity
there isn't that scarcity so if it's not
scarce if it's not special if there's so
much then it's it turns into blue-collar
it turns into a lot of people are doing
this at the factory they're all making
these things so I mean blue-collar and
they may make a living that is
white-collar they may you know their job
maybe you know maybe they're not
dragging cables around and that kind of
thing maybe they're doing something you
know nicer but it's less special and I
think it's good that there's that that
happen I think it's gonna I think it
would make the industry better what
about if people say well why should I
bother I'm not going to stand out is
standing out at an arcade
it's constant yeah I think it's standing
out your goal them or my project it's
not gonna stand out well I mean
sometimes good projects get buried you
know it's really hard to control the
world and what you're doing you know
again the movie was recently buried
because of all the horrific acts in the news
because they knew marketing wise that
was a bad move
if if you can as a filmmaker storyteller
artist whatever it is that you create if
you can find five people who like what
you do and you talk to them on a regular
basis and they tell other people about
what you do then that audience grows and
it grows naturally grows organically
grows slowly and the quality of the that
group of individuals who knows who you
are that changes I think what you make
and I think it changes you because you
know kind of who is it's gonna be
looking at your stuff because you talk
to them on a regular basis like I know
stuff about people and people are going
through stuff and there are internet
neighbors you know I know more people
online than I do offline way more
they're all over the place but it's and
I'd you know the we're all famous to a
few people thing is is the reality of
saturation is how many people does it
take for you to be famous how many
people have to know who you are to be
famous the weatherman in Minneapolis is
very famous in Minneapolis he's gonna
walk into an Applebee's and everybody's
gonna go the leather man's here that guy
shows up and here nobody gives a shit
they don't know who he is because he's
famous in that little little silo it's
like like the huge band in the UK right
now that none of us know because we're
not in the UK but they're huge over
there wolf Alice
I don't know but that's what I mean
there's always wrong yeah the little
silos you know all the Korean k-pop
stuff all that there's another silo
right I do a live streaming music show
on Wednesdays and people stay up I'm
amazed like Netherlands UK like it's too
hot in the morning we do one show and
some people make requests from
essentially with a tweeting youtube link
with a hashtag all I do is follow the
hashtag I click on the youtube link and
I play their request and then everyone
listening votes and if they don't like
the song that I stopped the song so it's
called song request cage match so it's
like your spring your song and see if it
gets beat up or not and so in Australia
someone requested something and there
was another Australian who is also on
and the two of them are going back and
forth about the song and they're going
on about it and I'm like I've never
heard of this song I have no idea who
this guy is I've know and they're like
Oh everywhere and that's what I mean
like those little tiny silos of you know
it's like the people who are really into
Game of Thrones that people are really
into one particular comic book that
nobody else you know and if you're not
into it you don't know about I was out
of barbeque and some guy walked up to me
it's like hey do you watch Game of
Thrones I was like no I can't talk to
you
and I'm like I'm not gonna feel bad cuz
you might or find something to get all
excited about the finale with but that's
slide those silos so when somebody says
hey have you ever seen that dirt scene
as a vampire mob thing well I was
vampire it's thing and it just popped
it's our do explain that's them telling
somebody else about your work bet them
saying I like this I think you might
like this that is the best marketing in
the world and you can't make that happen
you can't force that to happen you can't
just show up and crowd fund and make
that happen and you also can't show up
and crowd fun and then never crowd fund
again and then and disappear
seen that but literally why I was
looking up a documentary and I tripped
over some segments of it on like a Vimeo
and I went back to their Twitter and I
and their Twitter literally was we've
reached our goal and there was one more
tweet and they never tweeted again and I
was like wow that is some hardcore
opportunistic crowdfunding cuz you're
not even gonna say anything past then we
hit the goal we're out
do they make the film it's not out parts
of it around it's been too long I'm
guilty of that myself with one of my
crowdfunding things so maybe something
went wrong but yeah that's that's that's
bad filmmaking that may not be actually
shooting but if you are going to crowd
fun and then stop talking the day you
make your goal or the day after you make
your goal you're doing it wrong you need
to keep talking those people forever
because that is gonna come out and
you're gonna do something else and I
I've talked to someone who is a big
supporter of mine who has contributed to
everything I've ever crowd fund it for
and she told me the people who I know
online who she had contributed to and
she said you know I never got any of my
purse ever from any of those project
you're the only project that I've always
got my perks from and I'm like really
and she said yeah I don't want to you
know say anything but they show up and
ask for more money and they didn't give
me the perk from the last one that's bad
filmmaking sorry because you're doing it
to make films and if you're crowdfunding
and then you do that you're messing
over your audience you're you're not
authentic you're ingenuine you are
you're exploiting people you're taking
advantage
and you're a jerk.